من جهه اخرى اكد الجيش السوداني للجزيره
استعاده السيطره على قاعده النجوم الجويه
في جبل اولياء جنوب الخرطوم واشار المصدر
الى ان القاعده كانت تحت سيطره قوات الدعم
السريع منذ بدايه الاحداث وتمت استعادتها
بعد معارك وصفها بالعنيفه داخل القاعده
الجويه اضاف المصدر العسكري ان قاعده
النجوم الجويه دخلت الخدمه فور استعادتها
من الدعم السريع حسب مقال
من ام درمان ينضم الينا مدير مكتب الجزيره
المسلم الكباشي لمسلم طبعا هذا اليوم
الثاني بعد انتهاء الهدنه المعلنه كيف
بدات حده الاشتباكات
في اليوم الثاني بعد انتهاء الغده ووصلا
للمعارك التي كانت البارحه تواصلت هذه
المعارك في ولايه الخرطوم بمدنها الثلاث
نسمع دوريه الانفجارات في مواقع مختلفه
ونرى تصاعد اعمده الدخان في الخرطوم في
جنوبه الخرطوم في منطقه منطقه الصناعيه
والحله الجديده ومناطق اخرى من الخرطوم
فضلا عن ايضا الخرطوم بحري في منطقه
الشمبات وغيرها وجنوبي اندرمان المعارك لا
تزال متواصله بكثافه في مناطق مختلفه من
مدن العاصمه المثلث الثلاث ولكن الخرطوم
التي كانت المركز الرئيس لهذه المعركه
التي اندلعت من حوالي ما يقارب الشهرين
الان تجدد مركز جديد او انضاف اليها مركز
جديد هو دارفور بالامس كانت هنالك معارك
ضاريه في مدينه كتم في شمال دارفور كانت
هنالك هذه المعارك الضاريه وكان الخسائر
كبيره في الارواح
والمعدات وخاصه ارواح فقط خاصه مستشفى
الفاشر بالقتله والجرحى في هذه في هذه
الولايه كذلك في ولايات دارفور الاخرى
وخاصه ولايه غرب دارفور التي عاصمتها
الجنينه وولايه وسط الدارفور زنك
وولايه وسط دارفور فقط
وصفها وصف دارفور كلها حاكم ولايه دارفور
من بانها منطقه منقوبه وطالبه المنظمات
الدوليه والمجتمع الدولي بمحاوله اغاثه
هذه المنطقه فقط فقدت المنطقه تماما
انهارت كل الخدمات خدمات المياه خدمات
الكهرباء خدميات الصحه
وغادرتها المنظمات الانسانيه واصبح الموتى
في كل مكان اصبحت
يتسلق
القناصه مواقع مختلفه واقتال الناس سواء
كانوا مستقرين او يحاولون الفرار من هذه
الولايات هي ولايات فعلا منقوبه تماما
وتحتاج الى الى اغاثه عاجله كما ذكرت كثير
من الوكالات التي انشغلت بهذا الموضوع
سواء وكالات سودانيه او وكالات غير
سودانيه
شكرا لك من ام درمان مدير مكتب الجزيره
المسلم الكباشي